après l'embargo décrété mardi sur les
importations de pétrole et de gaz russe
les etats-unis pourraient se tourner
vers le venezuela pour leurs besoins
énergétiques
le président maduro a confirmé avoir
reçu une délégation américaine ce week
end à caracas le régime est pourtant le
plus proche allié de la russie en
amérique du sud
nous avons eu une rencontre
que je pourrai qualifié de respectueuses
cordiale
très diplomatique mais parler sûrement
apparu très important de pouvoir parler
face à face
aux questions d'un grand intérêt pour le
venezuela
un grand intérêt financier notamment
avant l'embargo imposé en avril 2019 les
exportations de pétrole vers les états
unis représentaient 96 % des revenus du
venezuela outre la question de la
sécurité énergétique de washington le
sort de plusieurs détenus américains
auraient aussi été abordée après cette
rencontre joe biden annoncé la
libération de deux citoyens américains
par voie de communiqué deux américains
qui étaient détenus à tort au venezuela
pourront à nouveau embrasser leurs
familles nous ramenons gustavo kb menace
erreurs et alberto fernandez à la maison
un autre signe de ce réchauffement alors
que les deux pays ont rompu leurs
relations diplomatiques après la
réélection de nicolas sma dos rond en
2018 l'opposition vénézuélienne menée
par wang wei d'eau et soutenue par
washington aurait également pris part
aux discussions